herr keyboard denn umfangreiche
straftaten vorgeworfen er soll halt als
kommandeur einer eliteeinheit an der
verschleppung von oppositionellen
mitgewirkt haben
es gibt einen dringenden tatverdacht
gesehen warum haben sie sich den
argentinischen behörden nicht gestellt
warum sind sie nach deutschland begonnen
der in argentinien zu bleiben die
mitglieder von diese abteilung in meine
platte also da heißt die bischofsstadt
die kunst die waren die best trainierte
mörder von der diktatur
[Musik]
ich finde dass es vor dem hintergrund
der deutschen geschichte und sehr gut
zukommt oder das ist eine besondere
verpflichtung für deutschland ist solche
taten da ein umständen zu verfolgen und
zwar insbesondere dann wenn deutsche
staatsangehörige daran beteiligt gewesen
sein
[Musik]
12.000 100 kilometer liegen zwischen
berlin und der argentinischen stadt
nagelplatte dort würde man den älteren
herrn der hier gemütlich durch berlin
spazieren geht gerne sehen und zwar vor
gericht
sein name ist louis estate coburg
geboren am 22 januar 1948 im
argentinischen catamarca sohn deutscher
einwanderer coburg besitzt sowohl die
deutsche als auch die argentinische
staatsangehörigkeit gegen den ex marine
offizier liegt seit 2013 ein
internationaler haftbefehl vor
grund verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit belohnung 500.000 peso
damals etwa 7000 euro
am 23 märz 2015 stillen argentinische
behörden einen auslieferungsantrag für
coburg an die bundesrepublik
er soll während der militärdiktatur
zwischen 1976 und 83 an der
verschleppung und tötung von
oppositionellen beteiligt gewesen sein
nachfrage der bild reporter bei dem
gesuchten
die zeitung tv dürfen wir ein paar
fragen stellen
ich habe keine zeit geht und es gibt
einen fahndungs- und ein haftbefehl
gegen sie können sie mir sagen was zu
den vorwürfen
können sie mir sagen was an den
vorwürfen dran ist dass sie angeklagt
sind wegen verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit
hinsieht dieses verhandlungsplan es ist
ein auslieferungsantrag gestellt worden
dass sie nach argentinien bzw
in argentinien menschen umgebracht haben
soll 1976 was stimmt daran das ist
falsch
warum soll das falsch sein ihre
kameraden sind auch verurteilt worden
über die argentinische geschichte
die chronologie des terrors beginnt in
argentinien mit einem militärputsch am
24 märz 1976 übernimmt der
oberkommandierende der streitkräfte
troche rafael videla die macht mit
brutalsten methoden verfolgt die militär
unter unliebsame regimekritiker
willkürliche verhaftungen entführungen
und morde höheren fortan zum alltag
eines der zentren des staatlichen
terrors befindet sich zu diesem
zeitpunkt in mar del plata eine
hafenstadt südlich von buenos aires
hier liegt die basler war ein hoch
gesicherter stützpunkt der
argentinischen marine louis esteban
kyburg dient hier zunächst als leutnant
der offizier ist 28 jahre alt und
mitglied einer kampfeinheit der akku
passion buß taktikers diktator videla
setzt die elitesoldaten nicht nur
militärisch ein als todesschwadronen
führen die meiner operation gegen die
zivilbevölkerung durch brutal und
gnadenlos
in buenos aires treffen der rechtsanwalt
caesars ivo als nebenkläger hat ja schon
dutzende prozesse gegen die täter von
einst geführt jetzt wieder coburg vor
gericht bringen
timo war der zweite kommandant der
taktischen tore innerhalb der armee galt
diese truppe als absolute elite einheit
diese soldaten waren die die am besten
ausgebildet waren in den operationen
waren sie die motiviertesten und wenn
wir genau über diese einheit reden dann
muss man sagen dass sie eigentlich eine
sehr kurze einsatzzeit hatten dafür aber
mit einem extrem hohen maß an verfolgung
folter und hinrichtung zurück nach
modell platter
die meisten verbrechen diese einheit
fanden auf einem außengelände der basler
wallstadt direkt neben einem leuchtturm
hatte das militär eine großküche in
einer folterkammer umgebaut
laut anklage sind hier mindestens 152
menschen gefoltert und anschließend
getötet worden die behörden gehen davon
aus dass auch der stellvertretende
kommandant louis esteban kyburg
mitgemacht hat oder von den
misshandlungen und morden gewusst haben
muss
sie haben ihre opfer an den füßen
aufgehängt und steckten sie dann
kopfüber in einen wassertank dann ließen
sie nach unten in die tiefe sinken
sie hielten die opfer so lange unten bis
sie blau anliefen
dann wurden sie plötzlich wieder nach
oben gezogen damit sie nicht sterben
was passiert dann alle opfer die so von
dieser kampf firma einheit in diesem
tank gefoltert worden sind erlitten
schwere herz und lungenschäden ausgelöst
durch den enormen druck auf und druck
abbauen
dieses schnelle ruf und abziehen war
äußerst schlimmen für die lunge und das
herz das machte diese spezialeinheit das
waren coburg und seine leute der terror
gegen die eigene bevölkerung dauert
sieben jahre am ende der diktatur 1983
sind mehr als 30.000 opfer zu beklagen
die meisten täter können untertauchen
erst jahre später kommt es zu den ersten
anklagen
die verhandlungen ziehen sich in die
länge im april diesen jahres endete der
vorerst letzte prozess vor dem
bundesgericht in mar del plata von 35
angeklagten werden 28 wegen mordes zu
lebenslanger haft sieben männer wegen
folter mit bis zu 25 jahren haft
verurteilt darunter auch kommandeure
augsburgs einheit
sie haben im gegensatz zu den
verurteilten kameraden nichts mit der
ermordung von den menschen zu tun diese
kameraden und sind sehr schöne personen
was haben sie denn gemacht in dieser
zeit 1976 wo bis 83 wurden mehr als
30.000 menschen sind wir schon den
daumen und ich weiß mein deutsch ist
schlecht
sie waren kampfschwimmer einer einheit
und sie waren mit so lautet die anklage
beteiligt an aktionen gegen
oppositionelle
so steht es auf so wurden auch ihre
kameraden mit denen sie
zusammengearbeitet haben
diese klage ist
weil ich im mandl platter war in 19
1970 nach dem ende der diktatur arbeitet
coburg als jurist
noch ist er nicht in das visier der
ermittler geraten 2013 werden sieben von
13 kommandeure die meisten dienten auf
der basler war wegen mordes zu
lebenslangen haftstrafen verurteilt
darunter auch konteradmiral juan carlos
mamani kommandeur von kühlbox einheit
und ein weiterer kommandeur
fregattenkapitän juan carlos patrício
auch kühlbox direkte vorgesetzte kapitän
zur see rafael alberti dazu bekommt
lebenslang in einem zeugnis belasteter
kühe boxspiel zitat im kampf gegen die
subversiven zeigt er das höchste maß an
verantwortung
er war beteiligt an den einsätzen der
spezialeinheiten coburg taucht unter und
kann sich so eine anlage entziehen
2013 wird er mit einem internationalen
haftbefehl gesucht am 21
2014 werden die argentinischen behörden
von interpol informiert keyboard lebt in
berlin mit dem deutschen pass fühlt sich
lewis esteban coburg in der hauptstadt
sicher er kann nicht ausgeliefert werden
auch der deutsch argentinische toni r
wieder lebt in berlin
er ist journalist und berichtet seit
jahren über die gräueltaten der
militärjunta aus seiner heimat
dass ausgerechnet einer der
hauptverdächtigen ganz in seiner nähe
liegt erfährt er durch einen zufall
also wer in eine veranstaltung haben ja
im rahmen von dieser veranstaltung eine
live-schalte gemacht zudem
staatsanwaltschaft in mandel platte
einfach für sub so nach fünf sind
zuständig gewissen es glaube ich und er
hat uns bestätigt dass sie ihm wie eine
von dieser gesuchte personen in
deutschland zuflucht gefunden hätte und
dann haben wir angefangen zu überlegen
wenn ein deutschland ist wie kriegen wir
hin also was können wir machen und nach
eine lange zeit dann haben wir einen
informationen bekommen dass er sich in
berlin aufhielt
sofort macht sich wieder an die arbeit
recherchiert in den akten
versucht herauszufinden wo sich der
gesuchte ehemalige marineoffizier
auffällt das gefühl dass ich ihn wir
jetzt was unternehmen könnte und ein
bisschen gerechtigkeit und alles was in
argentinien passiert das wiederum von
30.000 verschwundene und sieben jahre
brutale diktatur und viele bekannten von
von mir haben jemand verloren also ich
persönlich nicht und es war mir klar ich
werde jetzt was unternehmen nach monaten
recherche kann er wieder sein landsmann
ausfindig machen
der gesuchte lebt mit seiner frau in
berlin pankow der journalist will sicher
sein film kyburg und vergleicht die
bilder mit alten fotos was natürlich war
es mal so ein komisches gefühl weil ich
dir vor jemand einfach schon einiges
getan hat also nicht wie ein
ungeheuerlicher mensch und er hat sich
sehr sicher gefühlt also da hat ihn
nicht den eindruck gehabt dass ich
jemanden der verfolgt ist oder gesucht
ich habe nicht den eindruck dass er
vorsichtig ist oder dass er am versuch
sich zu verstecken oder sowas
toni r wieder wendet sich an den
berliner anwalt wolfgang kaleck der
jurist beschäftigt sich seit jahren mit
menschenrechtsverletzungen im falle
eines prozesses gegen coburg wird er die
nebenkläger vertreten karl eck steht in
kontakt mit angehörigen der terroropfer
und hat akteneinsicht dem keyboard
werden umfangreiche straftaten
vorgeworfen es steht ja nicht alleine
auf der anklagebank und er soll halt als
kommandeur einer eliteeinheit an der
verschleppung von oppositionellen
mitgewirkt haben und diese verschleppung
wird juristisch als in führung
qualifiziert die leute sind dann in
kleine stine
haftzentren überführt worden dort sind
sie alle fast ausnahmslos gefoltert
worden und anschließend hat man sie wie
der ausdruck lautet verschwinden lassen
so und einer der fälle ist eben der oma
roger aber dem herrn keyboard werden
mindestens 18 weitere fälle vorgeworfen
oh mama rocci ist gerade 19 jahre alt er
will studieren und arbeitet in mehreren
sozialprojekten am 18 september 1976
brechen todesschwadronen in seine
wohnung in mar del plata ein und
verschleppen ihn seitdem ist er spurlos
verschwunden
die argentinischen behörden sind sich
sicher die männer kamen aus kühlbox
einheit anna hima roger die schwester
von oma erfuhr von fribourgs neuer
aufenthaltsort
sie reiste sofort von buenos aires nach
berlin beauftragte anwalt kar lag
[Musik]
ich bin hier in deutschland weil einer
der täter der auch auf der basis war auf
der mein bruder entführt gefoltert und
ermordet wurde
in diesem land lebt wir haben den wunsch
nach gerechtigkeit jetzt versuchen wir
ihn von hier also von deutschland aus
vor gericht zu stellen
er ist eine person die in diesem land
auf der flucht ist
er wird nur dadurch geschützt weil er
die deutsche staatsbürgerschaft besitzt
und deswegen nicht ausgeliefert werden
kann um in argentinien verurteilt werden
zu können
deshalb haben wir uns entschlossen auf
der suche nach gerechtigkeit uns an die
deutsche justiz zu wenden
seit dem auslieferungsersuchen 2015
beschäftigt der fall auch die berliner
generalstaatsanwaltschaft trotz
haftbefehl für eine festnahme fehlen die
rechtlichen voraussetzungen
wir müssen nach deutschen maßstäben nach
deutschen rechtsgrundsätzen gucken darf
die person in haft genommen werden
das setzt voraus einen dringenden
tatverdacht und einen haftgrund und den
dringenden tatverdacht zu belegen bei
einer auslands tat noch dazu einer
derart komplexen auslands tat wie es
diese verbrechen während darunter
normalerweise sind das ist ein sehr
aufwendiger prozesse und da gilt in
deutschland die unschuldsvermutung
solange wir diesen dringenden
tatverdacht nicht erbringen können
bleibt die personen in freiheit und ich
muss beweisen dass der angeklagte der
dort vor und sitzt dafür die
verantwortung hatte und dass er zu dem
zeitpunkt als er seine tat begangen hat
als 1976 oder etwas später wusste was
passiert mit diesem menschen nachdem ich
mit ihm zu tun hatte und das ist
ambitioniert aber ich denke dass das
eine herausforderung der wir uns stellen
müssen dass er im visier deutscher
behörden steht weiß louis esteban
kraiburg schon länger sorgen bereitet
ihm das offenbar nicht
die idee also sie rechne mit einer
anklage
ich weiß gedicht
ich wollte
unschuldig und sie sagt angela die ruhe
könnte bald vorbei sein
demnächst wollen vertreter bei den
ermittlungsbehörden nach buenos aires
fliegen zu zeugenbefragungen in der
ermittlungs sache kyburg
[Musik]
[Applaus]